le face- à faceace de ce soir forcément
avec Issa dumbia on débute pas face à
face avec Marinho il est où c'est pas
lui qui fait le face à face vous êtes
trompé d'émission et d'années on aurait
pu ressortir les images ce dit il y a
quelques années on débute par un CV
Express interrogatoire rapide pour mieux
cerner Issa dumbia nom prénom dumbia
Issa âge 29 ans profession comédien dans
tous les genres lieu de résidence Paris
maintenant nationalité française
activité pratiquer loisirs euh tout
c'est bien c'est comme ça Mang manger
boire is on parle de votre parcours
depuis tout à l'heure de votre actualité
aussi mais on a pas tout dit on n pas
parlé du Jamel Comedy Club vous animez
une scène une scène ouverte et vous êtes
pas tout seul sur scène c'est Alban
Ivanov qui tout à fait Alban Ivanov qui
que j'ai rencontré à l'époque justement
grâce à desclic Théât puisque on faisait
des des des
championnats avec la liid à l'époque la
Ligue d'ov tion des evelines et du coup
c'est c'est devenu un ami ça fait plus
de 10 ans qu'on se connaît et on partage
la scène ensemble on a partagé beaucoup
de choses on a fait l'émission wesh
ensemble on a fait ça c'était sur Cap 24
exactement on a fait aussi Canal Street
pour l'émission la première émission en
direct sur le site de Canal plus donc on
partage maintenant la scène ensemble et
dans quand on quand on aura chacun notre
temps et ben on
le même temps et ben on fera notre
spectacle ensemble vous travaillez sur
le spectacle ensemble parce que là on
peut vous voir ensemble sur scène au
coméy club donc pour ponctuer des
séquences où il y a d'autres artistes
qui viennent voilà c'est la DEP Jam
coméy et parfois c'est Alban tout seul
et parfois c'est moi tout seul quand on
n'est pas dispo mais mais nous on
rêverait d'écrire notre spectacle
ensemble Alban nous l'avons demandé
quelques mots sur Isa forcément on l'a
rencontré petit message pour Isa Alban
Ivanov issu de des clic théâtre qu'on a
pu voir cet été aussi au cinéma
d'ailleurs on s'est rencontré dans une
boîte qui s'appelle le rectum qui une
boîte échangiste non c'est pas vrai et
où on s'est vraiment rencontré et pris
d'amitié c'est au championnat de France
en 2001 att trrappe on faisait le quintê
d'un pro au Comedy Club on l'a fait
ouais pendant 1 an et après Jamel il
nous a proposé de présenter la scène
ouverte voilà en duo avec avec Issa pour
moi Issa ça ça a toujours été un grand
moi je suis dans dans dans ma famille je
suis l'aîné de deux petits frères avec
ça j'ai toujours été son petit frère
quoi c'est c'est c'est c'est un exemple
c'est un exemple j'aime
bien toujours il a toujours été
professionnel et il l' toujours ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a
toujours plusu chez lui il m'a toujours
motivé Issa grand frère décidément ça
fait plein de petit frères plein de
responsabilités bah c'est c'est ça c'est
je pense que ça vient vraiment de la
compagnie des click Tart puisque euh on
nous apprend vraiment tout c'est-à-dire
le partage déjà c'est c'est vraiment la
base de de la compagnie et de pas faire
de différence avec les gens et je men
rappelle quand j'étais petit on
apprenait même à rouler des câbles et et
mettre en place la patinoire et tout ça
ce qui aujourd'hui me permet de
rencontrer des gens euh des techniciens
et de savoir ce qu'ils font aussi euh
euh et que c'est pas juste des
techniciens dans une salle et on peut
partager euh en parlant de tout et de
rien et Alban euh c'est c'est c'est je
sais pas j'ai pas de mot pour Alban
c'est c'est vraiment tout on partage on
parle vraiment c'est un confident c'est
c'est mon frère c'est c'est une fierté
c'est c'est c'est plein de choses pour
moi ce qui est marrant parce que vous
avez parlé de votre parcours à tous les
deux et des des des scènes des
animations que vous avez pu faire il y a
aussi un petit sketch qui a été fait
dans dans le service après-vente d'Omar
et Fred vous aviez piqué leur place le
temps d'une séquence dans l'émission
d'ailleurs ex B c'est Omar et Fred ils
ont toujours été là pour pour répondre à
à nos à nos nos questions quand on était
perdu parce que ce milieu on peut croire
que c'est facile et que c'est facile
aussi d'accès mais c'est c'est très
compliqué et quand on est perdu ben on
cherche des repè et et har ça a été pour
moi souvent un repère et Fred également
donc du coup quand on est peu on est un
peu perdu on va chercher les grands
frères et ça avance plutôt bien pour is
dumbia projet c'était donc un tournage
qui est déjà passé avec donc Daniel
Cohen à laffiche de comme un chefement
avec Jean Renault Michael h che
exactement le tournage est passé hein le
tournage est terminé c'est en boîte
demain je vais faire la post synchro
donc quand on a loupé quelques quelques
phrases ou quand on les a mal dites et
ben du coup on repasse en poste synchro
et a priori j'ai j'ai pas grandchose à
faire et ensuite
et et quel rôle alors dans ce film bah
je suis un cuistau je suis un un cuistau
et et j'ai pas d'accent et euh et on me
prend pour pour pour mon talent et pas
pour et pas parce que je suis un black
ou quoi qu il reste quelques minutes
encore d'émission on va regarder juste
une photo faire réagir sur cette photo
c'est quoi ah c'est une photo gentille
qu'on va voir apparaître à l'écran c'est
la photo de Norel Yakin Louise alors
c'est qui Noel Yakin ben lui c'est c'est
mon pote de de de de toujours
lesir qui d'arriver sur ce plateau
bonsoir vous pouvez poser des questions
à l'invité je vais faire mon laent rier
là est-ce que l'alliance est-ce que le
l'invité qui dit souvent l'alliance sat
te nique le doigt ah ouice je
connais alors desclic théâtre également
bonsoir merci d'être venu en clin d'œil
comme ça pour pour Isa vous avez un
parcours lié tous les deux tout à
l'heure il nous l'a expliqué c'est Nono
nurel Yakin qui est venu chercher Isa
dans la rue je suis pas V chercher
moi il a eu un problème très jeune c'est
beaucoup de gens ne savait pas où il
habitait c'estd que pour beaucoup Isa
c'est quelqu'un de d'un
quartier c'est une petite une petite
maison enfin un petit quartier de petit
plein petite maison dans la prairie
posée à trappe qui s'appelle Jean el
voilà c'est ça
et en fait il ça il s'est fait une
réputation d'habitant de Jean fll
c'està-dire qu'un jour mon père l'a vu
sortir de chez lui il lui a dit mais tu
habites ici tu habit à domier je croyais
que tu habitais là et en fait il ça
voilà il était tout le temps devant chez
moi à balader son chien lui faire ses
crottes devant chez moi à nous faire
grper aUard et à faire son
petit ouais vas-y c'est bon tu peux le
dire non j'ai des comptes à régler alors
je viens pour ça allez il nous reste 5
minutes même pas non gentiment en tout
cas ouais ouais il passait devant chez
moi un matin où j'allais voilà à mon
poste à Déclic Théâtre à la pointeuse et
euh et Isa il est il était là avec son
cartable alors que je savais qu'il était
inscrit au chaînet à l'école et et je
lui dis rentre tu vas prendre froid pour
faire ça parce qu'il l' a déjà raconté
et alors aujourd'hui vous pensez quoi de
son parcours et bien écoutez euh je ne
peux en penser que du bien je ne peux en
penser que du bien parce que il l'a fait
euh je pense sans triché il a euh tout
au long de sa formation à des clics ou
ailleurs su gommer les erreurs euh qui
pouvait lui faire défauts et et il y en
avait quelques-unes hein parce que bon
des fois ça se chamaillait souvent avec
Isa parce que c'est quand même un un un
beau caractère et on dirait pas comme ça
on dirait pas non mais je vous dis il a
fait non non mais c'est pour ça qui
mérite tout tout ça parce que j'ai dit à
un moment au début avant je tapais avant
de parler premier le premier rapport que
j'ai eu avec Issa quand il a intégré
l'équipe des junior de trappe ça a été
tout de suite un rapport de force dans
un minibus qui nous emmenait en province
je répète que c'est pas moi qui te
mettait des coups de pieds dans le dos
et je sais et moi j'avais la
responsabilité de les conduire et et
j'ai cru qu' ça effectivement m'empêcher
de conduire je rgle mes comptes
aujourd'hui ça et on s'est retrouvé sur
une air de repos à à mettre les points
sur les Z mais bon on en est revenu la
preuve à courir au du minibus et
aujourd'hui Isa donc à laffiche de
beurre sur la ville merci kinis d'être
venu sur ce plateau en clin d'œil pour
Issa qui va je m'en doutter ne pas me
laisser finir cette émission merci
d'être venu is ça non menlève plus j'ai
plus les micros par parce qu'on VO non
mais Wilfried parce que Wilfried beau
gose laisse prendre ma place voilà
hop au revoir tranquillement on va la
faire comme ça voilà
merci toute l'équipe un bisou euh oui je
te fais un bisou c'est bon comme du
poulet RTI he déshabillé que d'habitude
il est toujours habillé WIF donc merci
réalisation Xavier Jalin merci Joan sou
qui éta avec nous également sur le
plateau d'avoir bien calé cette émission
et je commence à être un petit peu
excité alors on va rendre l'antenne
merci beaucoup et à très vite à demain
mon
cochon